a transitional figure i don't think so i
think
transformational is what joe biden is
setting out to do and and by the way
if you look at how the metrics of his
progress
is that he always overshoots the runway
instead of underperforms
the thing is [ __ ] when you overshoot
the runway everyone on the plane dies
[Music]
[Applause]
so talk about weird medicaid
contemplated but this plan is going to
help those families
and create jobs for our caregivers with
better wages and better benefits
continuing to cycle growth everyone
there was fully vaccinated and yet
we see a near empty room filled with
fearful eyeballs darting above their
masks like a room full of coked up
surgeons
did remind me of his campaign rallies
but i would wear a mask too
to just cover the smell of bull
did you hear this and we won't ignore
what our intelligence agencies have
determined to be the most lethal
terrorist threat to the homeland today
white supremacy is terrorism we're not
gonna ignore that either
well that's a first telling the american
public that the problem is
within the american public
my feeling is if you're the unifier in
charge
you better back that up with some data
or shut the hell up
because if you don't have the numbers
you allow the media to smear millions of
people
and maybe that's the point unify but
then crucify
so it's another confused tiding from the
prez in the plastic bubble the guy sends
more
mixed messages than a stripper
seriously she gives me all this
attention
then she does the same thing with
another guy
it wasn't all bad because the bar for
all bad
is now gone it was barely capable like
watching grandpa reading his own eulogy
if the funeral home had a teleprompter
and grandpa had left
everything to his cat it had all the
drama and urgency of a tupperware party
hosted by the lady
who's fallen but can't get up
of course the greatest achievement he
took credit for
after i promised we'd get 100 million
covet 19 vaccine shots
into people's arms in 100 days we will
have provided over
220 million covert shots we're
marshaling every federal resource
we've gotten vaccines nearly 40 000
pharmacies
and over 700 community health centers ah
so now we have two
dr bidens thank you joe for also
discovering the polio tetanus and
measles vaccines
hunter's especially grateful you
discovered penicillin
but talk about plagiarizing he's like a
relief pitcher who comes in and gets the
last out of a no-hitter
of course the main thing that helped
beat this pandemic were the vaccines
ordered and sped up by noted science
hater donald trump
when trump announced operation warp
speed he was mocked by famous scientists
like dr joy behar
and dr dr whippy goldberg who assured us
that such vaccines would take
years and years trump did it in nine
months
joe biden took credit for it in just a
hundred days that's a fact gloria
and of course everybody understands that
operation warp speed happened
under joe biden but getting vaccines
into
arms was uh abiding operation
actually operation warp speed started in
may
2020 the only thing joe does at warp
speed is raise
taxes or roll down the cellar stairs
after tripping on his bathrobe
the last operation joe had anything to
do with took place at a hair loss clinic
i think it was called operation joe
plugs of course cnn let that slide
because it's gloria borger who hasn't
said anything of merit
since the early 80s her early 80s
how did the media take to joe as a young
senator bide used to say
all the time to fdr are you sitting down
turns out they liked it an extraordinary
amount of the use of tone
uh at times speaking to a whisper every
single sentence
had a very clear point to it it ha and
every line of it had that
biden humility in it it was really
beautiful
i mean it was beautiful he's really
trying to bring the country together it
was
a make america feel good night
forget covid they suffer from fawning
stupidity
which can be just as harmful since it's
hard to breathe when you're kissing that
much ass
then then there's
tim scott's rebuttal and the media's
convulsive reaction
because all he had to do was wonder if
he's also experienced a different kind
of intolerance
i've also experienced a different kind
of intolerance
i could call it uncle tom and the n-word
by progressives
by liberals just last week a national
newspaper suggested my family's poverty
was actually privileged
because a relative owned land
generations before my time
and every time scott bravely counters
the narrative that america is hopelessly
racist he gets crucified by the woke
peace-loving utterly tolerant dems
some called him uncle tim but at least
no one called him fredo
there's some stuff there that may make
sense um in a sliver of
republican world but um in the news
world
i don't think will ring this is a speech
delivered from a planet where facts
don't matter which is where the current
republican party
resides so it's really not his fault but
it is his responsibility to get his
facts straight
this was standard republican pabulum
america is not a racist country
there's no racism here it's it i'm not
sure what the purpose of this was i am
shocked and a bit embarrassed for him
this was a lost opportunity
i'm shocked she's embarrassed there you
go the stark contrast between media
treatment of an old white male that they
can control
in a young black man that they can't i'm
not saying they hated senator scott's
rebuttal but today at cnn
all the blm flags are at half-mast
joe presents a vision that gets the
stamp of approval from the woke class
as he abandons any defense of the
working class class is dead
long-lived race tim scott by rejecting
the language of victimhood and hate
however
scares the media more than project
veritas's next release
here's the black guy who's on to them
right tim today
cues are being taught that the color of
their skin defines them again
and if they look a certain way they're
an oppressor by doubling down on the
divisions
we've worked so hard to heal you know
this stuff is wrong
hear me clearly america
is not a racist country
whoa did he just say america is not a
racist country
hear me clearly america
is not a racist country i heard him
clearly
how dare he say something so positive
about america
didn't he didn't he get the memo or at
least watch the oscars
i mean seriously has he ever even met a
black person
except for his family and many of his
friends and thousands of his
constituents
we're all racists just ask any angry
white male
so the whole country's my family now i
don't know
we sure haven't been acting like it
lately and you know what
there's a reason there's a phrase love
thy neighbor
because you need help with that right
nobody's got to remind me
love thy family but love thy neighbor
that's a different thing
you got to be reminded of that because
it takes work
and compromise and
respecting each other's differences hi
dottie
oh that's very cute
why would you feed squirrels
what a racist but what's more racist
believing we get to live in the greatest
country on earth who
says that we get to live in the greatest
country
on earth i am confident that our finest
hour
is yet to come original sin
is never the end of the story not in our
souls
and not for our nation the real story is
always redemption everything scott said
was positive and unifying
and it was despised by the media and the
democrats why is that
because they need an enemy and that
enemy is us they hate redemption because
it's what prevents the profits one gets
from division
it's also now something the left
condemns from a man who has the audacity
to be black and say such things
you can't push revolution in america if
you believe americans are actually
redeemable
instead you must believe that even the
black guy is a white supremacist
dr king please pick up the white
courtesy phone or whatever color
courtesy phone you prefer
we need you more than ever
[Applause]
let's welcome tonight's guests
she puts the badass invent their ass
fox news anchor julie banderas
he's so smart he tells simon what to say
the director of domestic policy studies
at the american enterprise institute
royd streeter
she believes laughter is the best
medicine but also percocet xanax and
valiant
host of the silly caterpillar station
cat tim
and everywhere he goes is an observation
deck
my massive sidekick and host of dubstep
on fox nation iris
no tires i'm going to go to you first
because you haven't been on a couple
days
how did you like the speeches i'm uh i
keep it real i watched them both to
their
entirety yes no matter how much it i
wanted to i sat through it and i wanted
to prove a point to myself
so there were some things in biden's
speech that i actually thought were all
right i
i think we should start our kids early i
do like the sound of uh three going to
school at three years old i think it
does give us a competitive edge get them
out of the house yeah i don't know about
the free college afterwards but
i kind of think when you get older you
need to work your way and go through
some bumps i don't know about the free
school
but there were some things that i was
like okay not bad then brother scott
came on and i was like
wow nice job but both guys
the president and mr scott
we're pushing bipartisanship right at
the same time protecting
their brand i also watched an old white
man
standing on standing on a podium
speaking with
a woman of color a really old
white woman as
one and two in case something goes wrong
[Laughter]
and then the the rebuttal from the
republican party was a proud black man
i'm sitting in my chair and i'm going
wow we made it
that's as equal opportunity as you can
get and we're represented
wow nice job but then i watched
what happened afterwards no one was
interested in bipartisanship
they went after tim scott they didn't go
after biden
and what i've learned in all our
equality what we've learned now
is that racism is not just for white
people anymore
calling him uncle tim then i'll be uncle
tyrus with him
because he preached the same thing he
told the truth this is not a racist
country
we all have obstacles we all have issues
somebody might hate you because the
color of your skin
or the size of your belly or the sexual
or your orientation
we all got it but we all have equal
opportunities and in that chamber
that night we saw the opportunities but
that's not what mainstream media was
interested in
all they wanted to do was tear it up i
listened to so-called black
men who call themselves liberals and
fighter for freedom and opportunity
trash him like he was ignorant and he
was a white man's dog
where does that language come from that
was back in the jim crow era that's how
they talked it was acceptable
now they do it politely because why the
brother had a difference of opinion
and it's disgusting i was saddened
by what these so-called news anchors not
opinion like this
yeah we tell jokes and we own it and we
give our opinion they push themselves
as anchors of people of the news of the
people and all they did was push a
narrative because
unfortunately division sells they
couldn't say both guys were elegant
both guys had a lot to say and we can
build from this moment because you know
what that doesn't sell
and that was sad to me very poignant
that was deep
it was deep i don't expect that from you
julie i know that last night
i know that last night you were probably
in some hotel room bombed out of your
skull
you barely knew where you were that's
close but i was actually at home i just
put the kids to bed i watched 10 minutes
of it and i turned on the crown
but i have to say though i did watch the
aftermath today
meaning the ass kissing yeah and it
reminded me much of i
kind of identify as an eight-year-old
boy and
when i watch like two people kiss on
camera it really truly grosses me out
right and like
seeing tongue and anyway that was
watching cnn
and i just couldn't watch like the
eight-year-old boy in me was like this
is gross
and why are we why are we seeing so much
making out on cable tv
yeah it's inappropriate just don't
identify as an eight-year-old boy near
the lincoln project
yeah i don't even know what that means
ryan because
they wouldn't care but i have no idea
what is your objective taken all this
well i think the response to senator
scott was very predictable right right
in the non-response to vice president
harris this morning who reaffirmed
the very same thing right when asked is
america a racist country and she said
uh no america's not a racist country and
you know uncle tamala was not trending
on my twitter feed i mean
she didn't receive anything for that so
it's very clear what's going on here and
here's here's what i'm
kind of puzzled by tim scott is a is a
pretty serious guy if you ever talk with
him he cares about public policy he
cares about ideas
he actually wants to see things change
he got into politics for the for the
right reason
right um that's not a particularly
common trait in the republican party
right now
party's in a little bit of disarray
right so they've been spending the last
four
years or so coming up with i it's my
take kind of a misdiagnosis
of the kind of trumpian appeal to the
working class to come up with
conservative sounding alternatives to
progressive ideas they've been working
on
conservative minimum wages conservative
child credits conservative
uh wage subsidies and all of these
things that that basically now have
created an appetite
for the kinds of things that joe biden's
putting on steroids
right and what they really could just be
doing is working on trying to get their
agenda through
rather than just trying to attack tim
scott because he's actually speaking
for most middle americans if you
actually look at how
people respond to surveys about the
american dream most black americans most
hispanic americans believe they're on
the way
like he was speaking their language last
night attacking him
um over in this kind of anti-racist way
without just like
essentially talking about the agenda
which has a wide appeal to americans
right now that's kind of what i'm
worried about
should have been a much easier thing it
just shows you where they are it just
shows you where we've gone
cat where have we gone
where have i gone look i i i kind of
went into a rage a little bit yesterday
uh when when joe biden said like the
government's the people
yeah you know like he called me the
government
which is the meanest thing anyone's ever
said about me
like ever like i don't steal money from
other people
right and then he you know stood up
there and made it clear that he
very much plans to steal a lot of money
from
a lot of people in this country and i
don't want other people to spend my
money
let alone people who think they need to
wear masks when they are vaccinated and
in a room full of other people who are
all completely vaccinated people are
saying oh you're doing that to send a
message it's like what message are you
sending
like get vaccinated nothing will change
for you
yeah it's i wouldn't care if it was just
stupid because it is stupid
but it's also harmful yeah when i was
watching i know we gotta go
i felt like i was watching the the sec
it was beneath the planet of the apes it
was the second one with the people that
lived underground
do you guys remember that yeah and
they're all really scary-looking the
morlocks
yeah were they called more locks more
locks yeah they ate the pretty people up
from the ground yeah oh i better not go
there
that is funny